[Music]
happy endings I have met several of your
cast members and first of all it's a
very funny show
very funny cast the other cast members
have said to me several times the set is
kind of dirty we we're not politically
correct it's kind of risque I'm gonna be
sued well that's what I hear is I hear
that you were the worst offenders yep
definitely but I feel like that's
something that adds to the chemistry
it's like you know a show that's good
with the back-and-forth we need to be
having sex are you the theme of the
entire night is I don't know what the
truth is no one's telling me the truth
is it what kind of things you're doing
tell me what you're doing that's that
makes you the worst offender on this
sexually-charged so nothing bad just in
between takes let's go into the trailer
bang one out and get everything let's
get ready for the next scene so I feel
like that's something that you know
every show you guys don't do that no way
I'm messing up this hair yeah
[Music]
got the best hair in show business I've
asked him why not okay
don't you I know nice thing to say if
it's candles involved
out of a lip yeah
[Applause]